大家好,我是馬克洋,然後今天我會分享一些跟期貨有關的主題
然後因為我自己是一個數學家又是心理學家
所以我的觀點有很多應該會跟市場上的老師的講法應該是非常不一樣的
然後例如說我非常不喜歡使用那些就是其實沒什麼用的術語
然後基本上我講就是都是一些這個心理層面和數學層面
比較直接明確的東西
好
然後
就是這個演講主題熊市中人穩定獲利
是因為工會那時候要先提前送繩
然後那時候一直跌
所以我就定於說這個一直跌的時候仍然忍定獲利的做法
結果這個主題送去工會送繩之後
國安基金就進場了
然後最近就一直漲
所以就是這個也是說明一件事情就是
我們完全不需要知道接下來的行情會往哪邊走
也是一樣可以賺錢的
就是你看我只是要預測兩個禮拜之後
我的演講主題是什麼
就直接就翻車了
就是最近就一直在漲
然後
好因為這個岩漲筆不能按上下
所以我會一直回去按上下
那我先簡單自我介紹一下
就是我是馬克陽
然後很多人叫我馬老師馬醫生就是實況的時候
但是我其實姓楊叫楊正
然後以前當過醫生高中的時候拿過一次科學奧運的金牌
就是當時地表最會考試的人
然後那時候在楊明創立表演藝術社
就當了一段時間舞台劇演員
然後楊明的足球校隊
因為紅石智慧的救生員
然後後來醫生當到最後我就
就不想繼續當醫生了
就覺得不太適合我
然後我就去當爐石的職業選手跟遊戲實況主
那爐石就是也是一個純數學的遊戲
就基本上是我
就是比較適合我比較擅長的遊戲
然後一開始我也同時有開補習班
然後當補習班老師
那現在就是大家知道的是一個當充交易者
然後
不行
每張投影片應該都有一些可以學習的重點
我們分析一下這個人的肢體語言好了
這個人他是在手摸下巴嘛
那我們講一下手摸下巴的肢體語言
就是
如果是橫著摸的話是在評估
如果是竖著摸的話是在做決定
那有一個很類似的動作是遮住嘴巴
就是通常是表示你不喜歡你聽到的話
或是不喜歡你自己正在說出來的話
那所以這一張照片
那所以這一張照片他的動作應該是
就是在評估
因為他是橫著摸下巴的
然後他的手抱在胸前
手抱在胸前是屏障
那很多的書上面會說屏障是表示不同意你的看法或是拒絕的意思
但其實不是
屏障是
就是這是我的空間
然後讓我在我的空間裡
那所以有時候他可能可以是拒絕跟不同意
但是在這個地方
就是他應該是
這是我的空間
讓我在我的空間裡面思考
然後做決定
好吧
我們第一張就學到了很多東西
還蠻不錯的
好 謝謝大家
欸你要幫我按上下是嗎
你看有一個好的營業員
還可以幫你按投影片的上下
這服務多好
好
然後因為我是一開始當醫生
後來沒當醫生嘛
所以很常就被問到問題就是
就是當醫生當到一段時間
然後不繼續當醫生
父母會支持嘛
那當然一開始父母當然是很不支持嘛
而且我一開始是去打遊戲
然後還有創業開補習班
就是都是
這個傳統來說比較
就是不是那麼正當的事情嘛
對不對
正當就是當醫生啊
當律師啊這些的
然後爸媽也是怕我會賺不到錢
然後那時候我就是跟父母說
基本上我就維持一直是我同年齡的醫生
三倍以上的收入的話
那就讓我試試看繼續當醫生
然後那時候我做實況做的也還可以
然後就是在這個
這個月的上半月
我在當充交易已經從股市
就是從7月1號到7月15
上半月已經獲利超過兩百萬
然後而且中間有一個禮拜是
就是一邊旅行一邊交易的
然後就跟我媽媽分享
就是說我上半月已經賺兩百萬了
然後我媽就說
啊我就知道
小時候我就知道你最會數學了
還好你沒有當醫生
對不對
啊我就知道你最適合這種數學遊戲了啦
其實爸媽也不是說一定要你不要做什麼
就是希望你過得好
然後希望你過得開心就可以
然後對就是上半月
這個剛好7月就是我想說
我每一天都PO當天的對賬單
然後這個大家可以在FB上面
我的粉專上面看
就差不多加一加就超過
上半月就超過兩百萬了
然後目前到今天為止
就是前16個交易日
我目前是每天PO對賬單
然後目前還沒有任何一天加總是輸錢的
然後不過這個我在7月也PO過兩次
就是說我台子騎的
不是說勝率很高
然後只要進場就賺錢
都不會看錯方向
我是打非常多次的單
然後可能每一天會有十幾單以上
那總體的勝率低於50%
但是呢
因為我是短停損長停利
所以例如說我日盤的主要策略停損是10點
那我可能停損個三次才損失30幾點
因為還有滑價跟這個交易成本嘛
那我可能一單停利50點
我就加總就會是賺錢的
所以這個有其中一天我有PO嘛
就是我是四次保本
保本就是同價位進出
然後四次輸10點
那兩單是停利的
所以勝率只有20%
但是這樣
這個就已經可以到
好吧 我就用
欸他好像會互相賺回饋
好 沒關係
因為我也自己有憋一個麥克風
那所以他每一單的勝率
就是低於50%
加起來都還是可以是賺錢
那這也是數學上更正確的做法
好 反正我聲音應該蠻大的
所以應該也沒什麼問題
那就是這是七月的照片
就是我最近
這個每個月都會大概花一個禮拜左右
就是一邊旅行一邊交易
那這當然是會降低我的盈利的
因為我平常在家
我可以看三個螢幕的電腦
然後再還有一個筆電
就是四個螢幕來使用
那出去的話就只有一個筆電
所以我就會縮小我的口述
不過就是可以比較愜意一點
就是一邊交易
然後一邊可以出去旅行這樣
那基本上
我的這個知識體系
主要就是數學加心理學
然後我的體系就是
數學可以幫助你支配錢
心理學可以幫助你支配這個世界的人
那基本上你只要可以同時支配錢又支配人
你就沒有什麼做不到的事情
基本上你想要什麼
基本上都是可以做到的
哇 我的音樂員好猛
我沒有跟他RAID過
他要知道什麼時候要換頁
然後
這個是我上一次講過的
反正基本上
我認為啦
學校除了數學跟心理學之外
其他的課全部都可以廢掉
就是愛選秀就選秀
阿 如果你想加入精英中心的話
你可以申請加入數學或心理學部門
比如說
很多的那個歷史跟國文啊
他們都喜歡
這個硬拗說
沒有我們學這個
歷史是學跟人相處的方法
我們學國文是為了學
那些古人被貶觀的心情
為了訓練同理心
那說到底為什麼要叫小朋友
就是去揣摩別人被貶觀的心情
這學習重點到底在哪裡
但是沒關係
你們還是可以申請加入心理學部門
好不好
這個是我對於有用的學習的這個一個想法
然後再來就是
另一個輔助的就是高校學習
有怎麼樣很快速的學習東西
這個我之前也有辦過講座
就是
基本上從前面可以看到
我這輩子學過非常多的東西
那我是非常有在高校學習
那其實基本上
數學、心理學、高校學期、支配錢、支配人
這些事情
我都不是只純講理論
我講的都是我自己有做到
而且我認為
可以輕易的被別人複製的東西
那當然實際上也都有讓很多人複製出我的成果
好
那所以這個知識的力量
好不好
我們引用達拉蘭知識的一句名言
知識就是力量
而我剝削多文
好不好
這個是這張
這個435的達拉蘭知識的語音
我一直以為是薄削行者阿州
不過好像是達拉蘭知識
所以有時候還是會記不清楚
好可以下一頁
然後
這個
好我可以很謙虛的說
我可能是你遇過最薄削多文的人
我加了一個可能
應該非常謙虛
好
然後
這個
呃
上一次的講座我就有講過嘛
這個我的做法
在股市裡面
主要是運用行為經濟學
也就是用數學計算人性的方式
那行為經濟學跟傳統經濟學
最主要的不同就是傳統經濟學
假設每一個人都是完美的數學家
經濟學家加經濟學家
然後會非常理性
不受情緒影響的做出數學上最正確的決定
但這顯然是一件非常荒謬的事
就是你從小到大你應該知道大部分人都是不會數學
也非常不理性的
那所以我們就要用行為經濟學的方式去計算
人都會一起犯什麼方向的錯誤
那這個在股市上就非常有用
因為大家都會犯同樣的錯誤
大家都會太晚停損
大家都會因為規則一起被券商斷頭
那你就會知道行情在什麼情況下有可能會反轉
好
那因為我們是季節性講座嘛
所以我們7月就來講一些跟除全息有關的有趣實戰復盤
因為我們現在是除全息季節
我們第一個講的是長榮的除息交易日
除息交易日的意思就是
當天的股價會因為除全息而降低
那這個長榮的除息交易日
今年是在6月29
就是前幾天
那這是今天
當天我在群組早上收入的一些數據
就是當天的每股大概都是
四大指數都是下跌在-2%左右
然後台積電ADR是在-1.7%
那夜盤也是收下跌100
台紫期的夜盤也是收下跌140點
也就是說這個
然後另外就是-1.77%的台積電
本身就會讓大盤下跌-70點左右
然後最後收入的數據是
這個長榮今天開盤會除息
除息之後的參考價會是
昨天收盤價108.5
扣18塊變成90.5
那這個是除息之後的平盤價
也就是說昨天是收在108.5
但是今天的平盤價是90.5
它看起來是差非常多的
好
那這個就是常常可以聽到廣播就會講這些
但其實這些都是非常有用的數據
那像這個盤前的分享就是你要知道
首先你的預期是大盤都是在下跌的
然後長榮是一個很大的全支股
所以長榮今天如果開高都是屬於比較不合理的情形
然後這個是我們看到就是從八點半我就開始觀察撮合
那因為我就預期有可能如果是開在這個90.5以上的話
我認為都是開太高的
那另外也是要跟台積電還有同族群的這個陽明跟萬海比較
那如果大盤開低
然後陽明台積電萬海都開低
但是只有長榮自己開高的話
那長榮可能就開太高了
那長榮可能馬上就會跌下去
那在撮合的時候就是現貨是一直有出現漲停的數字的
那但是現貨的撮合本來就是可以無力展示
就是隨便兩等因為是可以抽單的
那但是所有人都看得到那個在展示的數字
所以其實那個數字是一定可以影響市場情緒的
那我就一直持續的觀察撮合
然後到四十幾分的時候
這個長榮期貨的撮合還是一直在9594這個地方
然後到八點四十三分就是期貨開盤前兩分鐘
也就是規則上的禁止三單時間
那撮合都還是一直在93附近
那我原本的規劃是如果真的開到很高
例如說開到96啊97
我可能就會直接打50口以上的空單
就是如果你要直接空開盤價的話
你就是掛遠遠低於開盤價的賣價
或是你就直接掛跌停賣就可以了
那你就一定可以參與到開盤的這個空單
那後來是大概是只有開高就是一點多趴
那後來我就是空十口
那果然在開太高
因為長榮開高
但是陽明、萬海、大盤、台積艦都是開地的
所以他自己開高跟同族群跟大盤比都是開太高
那他果然在兩分鐘之內我就成功停利在90點
因為我是空92.1嘛
那我停損大概是在0.7塊左右
然後我停利就抓2塊
大概是
這個也是一個點啦
就是90.5是平盤價
那合理會再開低一點
但是90又是一個整數關卡
所以我就掛在90.1的地方停利
那就有機會是抓到這一點
那我這個是左邊出場
但也沒關係
就是是在一個合理的價錢
然後我的風險跟我的報酬
大概也是在1:3的比例
也就是說
我是短停損長停利
而且我失敗三次
只需要一次成功就賺回來
然後這也是
這單就成功在兩分鐘之內就停利了
好
那可以看下一張
然後
剛剛提到的就是
這個也是交易規則
就是
撮合同時你可以看到
這個現貨跟期貨的數據
但是
現貨都是隨時可以刪單的
在
就算9點現貨開盤前的2分鐘之內
也都還是可以刪單
那這也是合理的嘛
因為如果
期貨突然崩跌不能刪單也不太合理
那但是8點43分之後
期貨就禁止刪單了
所以目前已經掛上去的單
如果單量不是就是只有10張20張
而是有足夠的單量
那就真的會開在那個數字的附近
那待會會有另外一個類似的例子
也會使用到這個
這個是一個非常重要的觀念
就是8點43分00秒之後就禁止刪單
好
然後
就是
當天的8點45分
就是台積、陽明、萬海都開低
那但是
長榮
昨天收108.5
但是今天開92.1
還是屬於開高的
那其實這種開高
也會有一個影響因素
就是
他的
他
昨天收108.5
但今天開92.1
還是開高
但是他看起來是很便宜的
然後
事實上
市場上一定有非常多人
第一個
他可能不知道今天除全息
或者是他
知道除全息
但他其實不清楚
除全息到底是扣多少錢
這
這個都是非常
非常正常的事情
就是
就像我說的
在傳統
經濟學的想法裡面
市場上的所有人
只要交易這個商品
他就會很清楚
他假設所有人都會很清楚
今天除息就是除多少
然後他的
合理平盤加了多少
但是
一定有很多人不清楚
開了手機
怎麼那麼便宜
就去下單買
那好可以往下下一張
好那這就是兩分鐘就成功獲利4萬塊
好可以下一張沒什麼好看
然後
就是這個也是一個要記得知識點
就是操作個股的時候
你要觀察大盤走勢
還有同族群的聯動
然後跟大盤比較強弱
跟同族群比較強弱
那好這個就是
然後這個是
就是結束之後
我在群組複盤
講這個價格錯誤
基本上
我認為我有一個交易特色
就是我比較會抓價格錯誤
然後還有這個遊戲規則的一些漏洞或者是巧門
然後還有我比較能夠預測
這個人類有多愚蠢
然後我也知道人類會犯什麼樣的錯誤
然後我們要怎麼避免犯這些錯誤
以及我們要怎麼利用別人大家一起犯的這些錯誤
然後好
所以這就是就這樣
好
然後再來這件事情
它的影響不會是只有開盤
就是除息之後股價看起來很便宜
還有很多人不知道除息
這兩件事情都會讓開盤之後的散戶
有更高的購入意願
就是可能很多人早上起來看
九點 九點多
長龍怎麼那麼便宜
不是之前都一百零幾塊嗎
今天怎麼九十二 九十三
趕快買一下
這個是非常有可能發生的
那在大幅度除息的時候
很有可能發生這樣的事情
在去年的萬海
還有今年的這個陽明
就是在這個之前是陽明有除息過
那都有發生一樣的事情
好 可以看下一張
就是
陽明的填息速度是非常快的
就是當天陽明在除息之後的當天
他的漲幅是跟同族群來比
是非常不合理的快速
那所以這個的做法就是
你在九點之前
你預期有可能會有一波大賣單
所以你可能在這個地方可以進場到
例如說九十到九十二之間可以進場到
然後一開盤這邊就直接衝到九十五
那馬上又是一個大概快要接近三趴的獲利
那這個也是一個對市場的預期
那當然你這個先進場
你也可以是在開盤看第一單的單量
然後去把它乘以五十
作為今天的開盤量能的預估
好 那這個
細節就不講了
好 我們繼續往下看
好 那
這個也是六月二十九號
早上五點多
我可能比較早起一點
早上五點多講的
就是這個是籌碼面
就是長榮最近的氣息賣壓
就是外資跟投信都這個連續賣超兩天
然後賣超是比較多的
這邊有兩次賣超
然後昨天外資賣超金額第一名也是長榮
那所以這個大戶是站在賣方的
那但是我們觀察到陽明填息的速度
是非常快
而且有些不合理
應該是長榮萬海沒有漲
然後陽明就收加6.5%
這應該是打錯字
但是從前後文應該是可以看出來
是陽明漲太快的意思
然後所以我們可以觀察
長榮會不會也有這個現象
就是除息之後
股票數字看起來很便宜
這樣買入醫院大增
不用跟同住群連動
然後下面是陽明的籌碼
這個是當天6點25早上5點多的
就是會不會也出現陽明
長榮今天除息之後
長榮自己是三個族群裡面的太過強勢
那所以開盤如果買入就會是一個很好的選擇
好可以下一張
好然後順便講一個知識點就是
2020年3月23開始
主筆撮合之後
就是看盤軟體上就可以看特大單差這個工具
這個是從每5秒
集合進價撮合一次變成主筆撮合
才可以開始看到這些特大單差的數據
那特大單差的意思就是
每一筆單它在不同的股價會有不同的分界
那具體數字就是其實上XQX就知道
那反正你就知道
就是一次買很多張的人
跟一次一兩張兩三張買的人的數據
會被分開來統計他們的金額
那這是非常合理的嘛
因為一次會買這個100張50張30張的人
他們應該是就是擁有市場上比較多錢的主力
那一兩張買的人會是比較不能夠決定股價的散戶
那所以我們應該要跟這個可以決定股價的人同方向
然後不要跟下面這個一張一張買的人同方向
那所以特大單差是這個個股的日內波當沖
幾乎可以說是最重要的數據
就是如果你在學習的這個當沖系統裡面
那個老師沒有教要看特大單差的話
你就可以把那本書丟掉了
就是基本上他沒有因為2020年的改制而有進步
那這是超級久以前的事
就是過了三年多了
他都還沒有進步在用以前的東西
那沒有用特大單差當沖的數
就是直接丟掉
就是一點用都沒有
好我們可以往下看
然後這個是當天的盤中的數據
就是當天的大盤又是繼續下跌
那在當時長榮的特大單差是-10%
那這是非常少見的情況就是特大單差已經到-10%了
但是他的股價還是在強於通租群非常多
因為散戶買入的意願是超級高
特大單差 但散戶一直買把他給撐住了
那因為畢竟搞不清楚狀況的人比較多會是散戶嘛
然後當天 當時這個萬海已經-5.5%
陽明已經-5.1%
長榮還在-1.7%
陽明 長榮 萬海 基本上他們是非常聯動的通租群
那他們的漲跌趴數通常會在類似的數字
但是當天出現了這個非常大的脫鉤
然後也跟大盤脫鉤
那這個也是符合就是我在盤前規劃有可能會出現的狀況
好那所以在當天開盤的時候買入長榮的好處就是
漲的話你可以賺更多
但是如果跌的話你可能還會受到一些保護
甚至還是有一些小賺
好
那這就是大幅度除息之後
眼睛看起來感覺很便宜的力量
就是因為他的除息的那個數字的幅度是
這個超過10%
所以就是他的股價眼睛看起來就很便宜
那因為人是不理性的嘛
所以我們就是很有可能會因此大幅提高買入的意願
我記得我當天有在講說
看起來這麼便宜我也很想買
對不對
好那這個就是這個我一直重複強調的
傳統經濟學的預測模型都是人聰明又理性擅長數學
然後大家都是用賽局理論在和這個經濟學模型和這個機會成本的好幾個數字互相比較才做出決定
但是人類根本就沒有人是這樣做決定的嘛
那實際的情況就是人類蠢到不行不會數學
對吧
這個應該也比較符合大家從小到大生長的經驗
好可以看一下
好然後再講一個知識點就是配股配齊這個動作不會讓你的資產增加
就是配股配齊就是
一百零八塊裡面
他把你給公司的其中十八塊這個
先包起來
然後過一段時間之後才寄給你
然後跟你說
欸送你一點錢
但是那本來就是你的錢
會從你的資產中扣除
而且你的資金還會因此被卡住一段時間
然後如果你買的不是個股期貨而是現貨的話
那你還要再被課一些稅之類的成本
就是
所以配股配齊這個動作不會讓你資產增加
如果你還要被課稅的話
還會讓你的資產減少
那所以
特別為了參加配股配齊
或者是特別為了某一檔
這個股票他有很高的殖利率
而去買歐資產股票
是一個非常不好的理由
非常錯誤的決定
那但是
因為長榮配十八塊
很多人就會直接算
就說十八除以這個一百出頭
然後他的殖利率就是十幾趴
太扯了
然後所以很多人
當時很多人買入的意願
就大為增加
但是當時長榮卻是一個
持續在下跌的股票
所以就是很多人可能就從一百四
然後就一直報到一百零八
然後被出息
然後你就直接虧了三十趴
所以會不會賺錢的主要因素
就是應該說全部因素
就是這個股票在上漲還是在下跌
而不是他有沒有很高的配股配息
好
但是可以補充一點
就是所以要看這個填息的比率
如果這個最近十年或最近二十年的填息率
都是一百趴的工資
然後他的配股配息還不錯
所以你買入
那這就是一個還不錯的理由
好但是
只是因為殖利率很高
那買入
那就是一個非常愚蠢的理由
好然後
這個
好可以再看一下上葉
看一下日期
就是類似題
好不好
就是長榮公佈除息
下午公佈除息的第二天早上的情形
3月16號
好可以看一下葉
然後當天的大盤是開小高的
那這個
撮合的時候
長榮的試撮是一直維持在漲停
那因為長榮公佈的除全息的數字
看起來是蠻高的
那如果是換算殖利率的話
當時也是超過10%
那所以這個大戶就希望把這個
就是股價當天是不是有機會
開盤就接近漲停
然後直接就是直接供到漲停
最好可以漲停縮死
那想要這樣供的多方大戶
當然是自己手上持有非常大量長榮的大戶
那當時的長榮前一天是收158
然後當天的期貨是直接開到169
也就是加6.9%的地方
然後漲跌幅限制是10%
這應該大家都知道
就是一個全止股
直接開到加7%是非常不合理的高的地方
那相對於大盤
因為當時的大盤也沒有漲那麼多
美股也沒漲那麼多
所以它一個全止股要直接開加7%是非常不合理的
那當時就是從
一樣從8點半就開始觀察它的撮合
然後到8點43分的時候
都還是一直撮合期貨撮在169
那時候就已經是禁止三單時間
所以當時我就是規劃
就是我就直接一樣就是掛很低
空開盤
然後我就成功空到169塊的長榮30口
可以往下
好然後這一單就是一天獲利加54萬
好就是對賬單
一單就是30口就獲利54萬這樣
好然後當天的尾盤
我又再重新買回來
在142.5買回28口
就是是買在次月然後部分成交
那詳細的可以在YouTube上面看到這個的復盤
然後所以我也是一樣用一個很短的風險
就是最高就是漲停嘛
那當然可能你不能被關在漲停
所以你可能要設個173處架停順
然後173.5就會被打出去
那這樣才不會有漲停被關廁所
第二天又再跳高的增加了風險
然後當天拿到的獲益是26.5塊
那所以這也是一樣是一個很遠的比例
就是基本上你要有你的停損
就一定要有一個更長的停歷
就是你的停歷一定不能比你的停損更短
其實也不能一樣長
就是一樣長的話你就會虧交易成本
就是我一直持續在講的
就是短停損長停歷
那這樣的話一定會降低你的勝率
所以不要去追求高勝率
就是我們來市場是要追求長期一直穩穩的賺錢
而不是追求說啊長長贏好爽
然後就是連續贏了十幾單
然後最後這個例如說你每一次你都停損4.5塊
停歷0.5塊那你就會很常停歷嘛
然後可能這個虧一次就直接把你一整個月賺的全部虧回去
那這個是一定要避免的
然後另外一個短停損長停歷的好處就是
你不會有任何一天是大賠的
就是因為你每一次停損都很短
然後你可能幫自己設定一個紀律
比如說今天連續停損三次
今天就停止交易
那所以你最多就是短停損的三倍
讓你今天就不會繼續交易
那這個紀律的做法也是避免自己打到on
就是on tilt 就是上頭
就是做出不符合自己平常策略的決定
好 可以往下
好 所以我們要用小風險換取大的報酬
好 繼續往下
好 然後這個是長榮期嘛
當天的線圖就是
我們可以從這一段上面來看到
就是當天我是成功賣在169這個地方
然後買回來在142.5這個地方
一天就賺了這麼長一段
那相對於其他天來說
這是就是
剛好是賺到一個非常非常大的事件
好 可以往下
好 那這個來回大概就是差150萬
就從正7%到-10%這樣
好 那接下來我們講一個遠近月價差策略
就是這個月的策略
這個是一個非常有趣的非常巧妙的策略
那我們先講一下遊戲規則
就是這個我們交易的商品是台紙期
然後因為我怕大家
就是有一些人不太了解交易規則
然後台紙期的結算日是每個月的第三個禮拜三
那所以7月就是會在7月
7月中會結束7月的合約
然後8月中會結束8月的合約
然後最後的結算
台子期期货的最后结算的价钱是
结算日就是最后一天的结算最后30分钟内
标的指数的算数平均
我就不讲太细节了
就什么五秒揭露一次然后几个数字什么
反正大约就是猜最后一天的最后30分钟的价钱的平均
那现在价钱如果是在16000
那你要猜10天之后的结算价
最好的猜法就是猜16000对吧
那虽然10天之后大概不会结算在16000
但是你猜高了跟猜低了都不合理
所以你就会去猜16000
那这就是台子期会一直跟着大盘点数
台股指数期货
这个会一直跟随台股指数的原因
好然后有这个月的合约
也有下个月的合约
那所以这个月的合约就是猜
7月中结算那天的最后30分钟的平均数字
那8月的合约就是猜8月中那天最后30分钟平均的数字
有人还是听不懂台子期在猜什么吗
好 假装大家都听得懂
好 继续放下
然后这个游戏算的这个权重比例台积电现在是28%
28.26%
然后第二名的红海只有占3.18%
再来就2.44 1.99
就是台积电占了超过四分之一的权重
那所以这是为什么我一直强调
就是日盘的台子期当中最重要的就是一直看台积电的走势
看台积电的大单追踪
特大单差
然后这个大户买卖力
那因为它就占了超过四分之一嘛
然后前16档权之谷到这边就已经超过50%了
前16档占超过50%
占超过二分之一
然后台积电一档就占超过四分之一
那这是游戏规则
然后我们看一下有哪些
好 我们待会会讲到的富邦金
就是反正富邦金是权之谷
大家知道这样就可以了
长荣也是在这边
好 可以
好 然后再讲多讲几个背景知识
大家才能听得懂
因为后面的那个是比较困难的一个策略
也是没什么人发现或是在使用的策略
那就是期货的三大功能
就是避险投机跟未来价格发现
那避险就是巨额资金
因为持有的现货部位大部分是多单
那所以会需要一些期货来避险
那所以期货长期平均来说会是小小的逆价差
因为它要避险
然后再来就是这个当充交易者
也就是我们
当然也可以是其他的交易者
就是波段啊 更长周期也可以
就是投机
就是买了期货是为了卖掉
或是卖了期货是为了买回来
为了赚取价差
那再来就是未来价格发现
好
那所以这个的知识点是告诉大家说
就是期货的其中一个本质是避险
所以在比较远的未来月份的期货
通常正常来说都会比这个更近期的期货更便宜
就是越久之后越便宜这样
好
然后再讲下一个规则
我们要先把规则都讲清楚
就是待会会使用到词都讲清楚
不然的话大家不知道这个故事的巧妙之处在哪里
我们数学家还是希望大家可以共同的感受这个数学的巧妙
不要就是我把算式讲到这样
然后大家就啊
很有趣吧
然后大家都听不懂
这样也不太好
好
那这个除全息季节啊
就是6月7月
然后还有一点点的8月
就是会有很多的股票除全除息
那所以我们都会算到结算日
就是月中的那天之前
大盘会因为除全息而蒸发多少点数
我们往上几张
到那个全脂股的全脂股的列表
下面下面下面下面
下面下面下面
啊对对对对就是
这些全脂股比较大的全脂股
小的全脂股当然也会造成影响
但影响点数就很小
那这些全脂股他们除全息就会造成他们的股价蒸发
就是这个钱就从市场上消失
因为退回去给股民了嘛
那像刚刚长荣他除息18块
那是不是他的股价就平白无故
从市场上的108块变成90块
所以他就就是他的
好我有点卡住
因为我刚才要摆动作给那边的人拍照
好
然后就是
我刚刚讲什么
扣18块
就是
所以他的股价就因此在市场上蒸发
那他就会造成大盘的点数降低
那例如说台积电扣2.5块
那也就会造成很多点数不见
富邦金
例如说扣
今年扣3.5块
那他就会造成大盘的点数不见15点
类似这样
然后
所以我们就把
最近
就是
就是除息之前
的
那个点数给扣掉
就是
这一次的除息日是7月20号
所以我们就把
就例如说今天是7月1号好了
那我们就要把7月1号到7月20号这段时间
会除息
而蒸发的点数预先扣掉
我们往下看那个
就是说呢
例如说这个自表日期是7月4号
那我们在7月4号的时候
我们就要统计这个月
还会带增发多少点数
就是说
因为我们要猜的是7月20号当天的大盘点数
例如说现在如果是1万
好我们随便讲好了
例如说当天是1万5好了
我忘记当天是多少也不太重要
那你就不应该猜1万5吗
你应该猜1万4,850
因为在结算的过程当中大盘自己就会消失掉1百50点
所以你就应该要把现在的大盘点数扣掉1百5去猜
这样才容易猜中嘛
因为现在是1万5你猜1万5
但是中间自然而然就会不见1百50点
那你还猜1万5那你不就很吃亏吗
大家懂那个意思吗
大家听得懂吗
大家一直点头
那大家开始听得懂带增发是在猜什么
好很好
那所以知道带增发点数是非常重要的
然后不知道带增发点数的人
就会整个月一直觉得怎么逆价差那么大
为什么现在1万5150大家一直猜1万5
好刚退位太难减了
我们用好减的举例
那这个是在下一个月
8月17号要扣掉273点
也就是说这个数字和这个数字之间的差距
就是预估7月20到8月17之间会增发的点数
那这边来算的话是126点
就是这个数字扣这个数字
273间147
大家懂的意思吧
那也就是说呢
7月跟8月的合约之间合理来说至少要差126点
就是8月要至少比7月再便宜126点
这样才合理
然后因为次元月就是后面的月份要再有一个小幅的避险的逆价差
就是因为未来而再低可能第一个不一定要多少都可以
就可能两三点五点十点都可以
但是如果是正的话就不合理了
所以如果这个4月就是8月的期货跟7月期货的价格差距低于126
那就是不合理的情况
大家听得懂意思吗
大家一直点头
好看来
这个大家都听得懂
好那这个是7月4号的时候的做的表
那7月4号就是刚好大约是这个就是7月20的前两周左右的时候
然后好我们再往下
那所以当时估计7月除全息蒸发点数是452点
8月是126点
那也就是刚刚那两个数字的相解
好我们记得一下这数字
我们估计7月20到8月17之间会蒸发126点
所以8月应该要比7月便宜126块以上
好我们记得这数字
这是7月5号日盘的时候
看到7月4号的推估数据
好可以看下一页
然后其中我们这个后面会有一些列表
这个就是7月4号的时候估计到7月20前会除全息的
有哪些公司他们会除掉多少哪一天除
然后是公司已经宣布就是那天除
还是我们猜测会那天除
我估计就是猜的
然后会造成台值下降多少点数
那所以这些8.4.68
这些数字加起来就是刚刚那个126的数字
大家懂那个意思吧
这个是一个列表
好
然后这边是富邦金
估计是7月20号
然后会造成大盘下跌15点
好我们再往下
那这个是下一天7月5号的这个就是公开的除全息预估报告
那当天是7月6号使用
就是下一天
然后刚刚的这个7月预估跟8月预估之间是差126嘛
但是今天这个是差到152是差非常多对吧
那就表示他们预估的点数里面有几家公司这个移动到下个月
就是本来预估这个月出息的移动到预估下个月才出息了
然后这个我就去对照后面的那个一大堆的列表
然后发现差距最大的就是刚刚看的那个富邦金的15点
因为他在
他是估计7月20要出息嘛
然后他就一直猜大概两个礼拜后会出息
那但是到这个两个礼拜的分界的时候
都还富邦金都还没有公布什么时候出息
所以他被猜会出息的月份就从猜它7月出息
变成估计8月出息
所以7、8月的预估差距点数就从-126
扩大到-152
那当然还有一些其他的估计7月20的出息的公司
也被移到7月21了
大家懂意思吗
大家都点头
好蛮厉害的
我想说这次应该是一个很复杂理解的事情
好可以看一下一页
好
然后这个
这个萤幕脏脏的
这个是152
就是刚刚是126变成152
那也就是说呢
就是因为7月跟8月之间的价差出现了
非常大的差距
所以我们要怎么利用它呢
就是我们开盘前就
就是8.45开盘前
我们就已经有这个前一天的预估了嘛
所以如果今天的价差就是没有做出及时的修正
还是在-126再多一点点的地方的话
我们就可以去抓这个价格错误进行套利对吧
比如说如果今天的价差是-140
那我就做一个组合单
就是-140块的组合单
然后在价差扩大到-152的时候
再同时平仓我就会赚到这14点的获利
大家应该都-好大家都听得懂
哦大家一直点头真的太厉害了
好那所以我们应该要做的是
7月的多单跟8月空单的组合加差单
好哪一个多哪一个空自己回去想一下就好了
这个也不是很重要
反正一定可以一多一空
然后扩大的时候再一起品尝对吧
那哪一个多哪个空
这个回去自己看影片再想
我们会上传YouTube
哦然后那个PVT也都会免费提供给大家
所以其实也不太需要抄笔记
好
然后好可以再往下一页
嗯已经下一页了吗
好
好就是这边
然后复邦金就从预估在7月20变成预估在7月21嘛
那因为是拆7月20的这个下午1点左右的最后那段时间
那所以7月21就被算到下个月去了
那所以这个15点就从归给7月的蒸发变成归给8月的蒸发
那当然这边
这边的这几家
也都被移走了嘛对不对
有一些7月21的
所以这些
也都会
所以它的差距不只是15点啦
因为旁边还有一些其他小的架数
那不过因为这个数字最大嘛
所以最关注要关注它这样
好
可以往下
那这个是这个7月6号的早上4点半
怎么那么早
好应该是因为当天有看美股啦
美股是凌晨4点收盘嘛
那有时候我会看到美股收盘
就是凌晨4点
然后这应该是一个远近月价差的组合
然后截图
非常有机会有很好的价格
应该是说指的是七八月的价差
有机会有很好的价格
然后因为
因为昨天的预估还在126
然后今天是上调到152的第一天
有机会
没有大家都做出这个资讯的修正
然后法人也不一定有正确的修正
所以
这个
有26点原本预估在7月合约除息的
变成在8月合约除息
然后如果市场没有做出正确的修正的话
我们就有机会在这个152之下蛮多的地方建仓
然后到价差扩大回152的时候
再同时平仓7月跟8月的合约
那像这种价格错误都是非常非常稳的
就是我就会愿意直接建仓
这个30口大台50口大台这样
就是因为风险是非常低的
好
然后这个是
这个
一样7月6号当天
这个有一个群友的
他截图他的手机啦
就是
他问说是这个吗
当时的
价差是在-138跟-140之间
然后所以我们就成功的建仓在-140的地方
7月6号的时候
那我们在-140建仓
然后到-152平仓
那这就是一个
这个12点嘛
然后
这个
如果是
因为这个其实风险很低
所以是可以全杠杆
那
这个一口小台或一口大台
总共都是
920点是100%的保证金
那所以这样的话大概
就可以赚到1.4%
那这个才两个礼拜或是几天
你就很稳地赚到1.4%
这个绝对是一个
非常好的
这也不算利息
就是说
报酬吧
对吧
因为我们平常可能一年
这个银行都不一定给你1.4%
你抓到一个错误
过几天1.4%就入带了
那这个就是一个
非常好的一个价差套利
好
然后这个就是台股指数近月价差
那这个是前一个月的价差
最后是到-51级
那这个6月的增发点数大概是450嘛
然后最后到-51级
也是合理的
那我们是大概
好
这边是画这个最后一天
就是最后一天价差是
有扩大到-181
那所以我们在中间
建仓在-140
然后-151的时候平掉
然后又再抓到一个机会在
这个-139的地方重新建仓
然后-179的地方
就是结算日出掉
那这边又再赚了40点
那就算这个后面就是
另外一个操作
就是这个策略的延伸
一个复杂的
就是另外一个操作
那我们就
今天就先不讲
那至少
这边这一段
这个应该是大家很容易可以理解的嘛
就是抓到这个错误
然后扩大平仓
这样
好
然后所以这个风险是非常非常低的
那第一段
获利这个
加1.4%
然后后面又再获利了一段
加4.3%
那这算是一个
这个就是
完全就是你
去熟悉了解交易规则
然后从这个交易规则里面去抓取这个市场上面的
不合理的价格错误之处
然后从中获取利益
然后
就是这一套是
我完全是我自己这个发现跟想出来的
那因为我每一天都去对照那个七八月价差
去对照带真发
对照初旋期
然后所以我能够
自己独立的快速的发现这些价格错误
或者是一些这个漏洞
然后七八月价差单的这个商品
它的成交量也都是非常非常低的
就是几乎我一天打50扣
我就直接占当天成交量很高的比例
就是这是非常少人操作的商品
那今天就分享给大家讲一下
这个商品还是有很多可以操作的地方
好
所以这完全是一个用知识获得的一个报酬
我们可以看下一张
知识就是力量而我剥削多文
好吧
我们再引用一次达然知识的名言
好
居然被营业员妹妹跳过了
再来我们看下一个就是说
7月5号的时候
就是当天封盘又V转
然后多空都转
就是这个只是讲说
就是我们不需要去预测未来的行情
就是很多分析师都很喜欢讲什么
就是一直跌的时候就讲啊
往下看一万三一万二
跌回八千五
就是很喜欢讲什么
上看下看
其实都很没有意义
然后或是一直往上涨
上看两万
两万一
就是随便在喊价嘛
但其实那些都是非常没有意义的
就是我们要交易的就是当下
看到的数据
当下你看到什么数据
你就怎么做
当下的市场情绪
当下的大户的走向是哪一边
然后你就顺势交易
跟随这个市场情绪跟大户的方向
好
那就是反正当天7月5号是先崩盘
然后我们空到20口的224
然后10口回步在123这边
然后这一个100点就是直接就在崩跌的情况过程中就先赚到20万
然后下一张
然后在后来往上V转的时候
我有打到买到了这个434的台积电
然后往上涨收在446
涨回来的过程又再赚12万
这就是多空双赚嘛
就是很多运气不好就是多空双八
跌下去的时候亏一次
涨上来又再亏一次
那但是如果你是有这个顺势交易的话
你是有机会
跌下去赚一次
涨上来又赚一次
那这显然就不是什么
你可以事前这个分析师在那边预测
几点到几点的时候先下跌
几点之后开始反弹上廊
这个绝对就是观察盘中的数据
然后看当天的走向才有办法做到的
那当天的这个现货最低是在433
然后期货最低是在432.5
那所以我就是停损的话就是破心低嘛
所以就是一个两块钱的停损
然后可以换到这个一个12块的停力
那这就是一个6倍嘛
所以也一样是短停损去换一个长停力
那当天主要进场是因为观察到盘中
也是看特大单差
就是大户已经开始在买回来了
就是大户一直持续的在买
但是散户一直持续的在买
那我们就应该要跟随可以决定市场价格的大户
人家都是499 499 100张的台积电在买
那散户就一张一张一张
那个可以决定股价的程度是差距非常大的
好
可以放下一张
好 所以就是
依照当下看到的数据交易不要预测未来的行情
然后预测行情是很蠢的事情
好
然后这个很多人问的问题就是当冲很危险吗
那可以看下一张
就是当冲就是非常短周期的交易
所以你的聪明或是你的愚蠢都会被短周期给放大
然后所以当冲只是把你的好跟坏都放大
那如果你很蠢你就会很快的赔光
如果你很聪明你有很好的数学
你就会赚得非常的快
那所以它危险是在危险在你的愚蠢
而不是危险在它的周期和放大
那所以市场上最危险的两件事情就是
不会数学
也就是没有好的策略
那当然
如果你是一个强大的数学家
经济学家
但你完全交易的时候不使用任何的数学
你就纯粹凭感觉买
啊 我是杨明毕业的
杨明
好名字
买了
哈哈哈哈
这个
其实我一开始刚踏入股市的时候
我是真的是这样想
我
我就想
哦 杨明
那我是杨明大学的
那我是不是应该买这家股票
就是
那我也是数学家嘛
那
那但是我当时买
看杨明想买的那个感觉就是
虽然我不是数学家
但这看起来很不错
对吧
好
然后
另外一个最危险的就是不停损
那这个是
非常非常多人在做的事情
就是
他的不停损是因为他买的时候
他根本不知道自己的停损点跟停利点在哪里
就可能有一个人跟他说
这个不错
就买了
那他也不知道要怎么停损
也不知道要停损
所以不停损是非常糟糕的一件事情
那其实
就是
就是买入台积电
然后永远不停损
其实也是一个非常糟糕的策略
就等于是你永远猜他在网上啦
那所以
我在FB也PO过非常非常多次问
因为
很多很多的财经网红他都
就是从
台积电跌到600块的时候就开始讲
这个600块的台积电是天上掉下来的礼物
然后到580、570的时候
哇
600块以下台积电无限买
随便买
买到赚到
然后就买买买
现在就到到400到这个最低433
那现在又回到500
好
那所以不停损是这个最糟糕的是
不会数学不停损
好
所以你要踏入市场
你就要学会好的策略再开始交易
那要跟谁学好的策略呢
马赫阳
哈哈哈哈
好
谢谢
然后
这个
好
可以往下往下
为什么我们要依据数学交易
不能凭人性的直觉交易
好
我们这个
YouTube不带的同学
这个可能已经听过了
但是因为
这段很重要
所以我们就再听一次
好不好
就是
就是真的很重要
好
再往下
就是
这个
我们要的不是高胜率
我们要的是
高正EV
就是正EV
长期稳定的赚钱
然后低波动
好
再往下
然后只要停损很宽
胜率就可以拉很高
但长期输钱
所以我们要的不是胜率很高
因为我们要的是
短停损长停力
好
这个上次都讲过
所以台子期的做法就是
短停损长停力
不管是什么周期
如果你是80点停损
那你至少就要200点以上停力
你可以降低你的胜率
但是
你的期望值会提升
这个是数学上更正确的做法
因为
这样才是更顺势交易的做法
就是你在逆势的时候
你持有这单的时间会更短
你在顺势的时候
你持有那单的时间
会更长
那这也就是规则一
就是
更长的持有正确的仓位
跟更短的持有错误的仓位
这个最后都会
这个影片会上传YouTube
然后PET也会免费提供给大家
所以真的不需要一直抄笔记
好
然后
这就是交易规则
基本原理
规则一
更长的持有正确的仓位
更短的持有错误的仓位
听起来很像是废话
好
但是大家都在做完全相反的事情
然后
这个是获利了结
卖掉所有赚钱的股票
留下所有亏钱的股票
好
这个是非常非常多人的账户都会发生的情况
就是所有这个赚钱的股票
他可能他的想法是这样
就是每一个股票
终究我就在正5%的时候把它卖掉
那如果他一直赔钱
我就一直不卖
到海枯死烂的某一天
说不定他会回到正5%
我再卖掉
那所以我的所有股票
终究都会赚5%
这个就是他们的策略
其实买入台积电多单永远不停损
也是类似的逻辑
就是因为科技持续在上涨
那所以我预期50年之后台积电的股价
应该会比现在高很多
那所以我就永远都不要买
因为它是好公司
那所以这也是
就是非常错误的一个观念
那这样的话
你就会更短的持有正确的仓位
更长的持有错误的仓位
那其实就是上一次讲座
我讲这个
有非常多人都跟我说
哇这个完全是讲中他
就是他的APP开起来
全部的股票都是在赔钱的
因为赚钱的全部都卖掉了
好可以看下一页
就是人性会让不同的人都犯一样的错误
然后我们再往下吧
就是正确的策略是
赚钱的股票全部留下来
然后赔钱的都卖掉
去买赚钱的股票
这样才会更顺势
然后如果所有的股票
你买的股票都在下跌
那可能是例如说
美联储公布
升级三嘛
美国在面临这个40年来最严重的通货膨胀
所以全球大盘都在下跌
那你就应该把全部赔钱的股票全部都卖掉
那如果你不会做空
你至少可以空手嘛
那如果你有做空的策略
你再做空
那我这边要说的另一个点是
如果你有做空的策略
你再去做空
不是说看到股票都在下跌
随机一个地方去空一个随机的股票好了
那这样也不行
市场上最危险的两件事情就是
没有正确的策略跟不会停损
如果你有停损
但是你都在做莫名其妙
自己也不知道会不会赚钱的事情
那基本上就是
你就只是在政府开了赌场
随便丢钱进去看会不会赚钱而已
好我们重新讲一次
因为这段真的很重要
我们重新讲一次
就是跟上一次讲座有讲过一次
就是为什么人会太短的停力
跟太长的停损
那我们从最基本的就是DMU开始讲
Diminishing Marginal Utility
就是编辑效用递捡
编辑效用说的就是
你在现在再多获得一单位的某一个
东西而对你造成的益处的影响
那Utility就是效用
那也可以翻译成快乐之爽度
或者是就是让你的快乐增加的程度
那编辑效用是会递捡的
就是你这个吃了100个寿司
可能吃不到这么多
你吃了10个寿司之后
你再吃下10个寿司的快乐
可能就没有一开始那10个寿司那么多
对吧
那你吃了20个寿司之后再吃10个寿司
那个快乐又在更降低一点嘛
对不对
那这就是编辑效用的第一件
好
我会有突破的开心吗
突破是什么意思
就是我这辈子最高只吃20个寿司
然后这次我吃了30个
我觉得很开心
因为我突破自己
这个DNU是这样
就是最终会diminishing
但是前面其实可以不用
marginal utility
可以不用编辑效用递捡
就是你在吃第一个寿司的时候
第二个寿司的时候
可能还没那么开心
吃到第三个寿司的时候
你突然比前两个寿司更开心
这个是有可能的
就是你的编辑效用
可以在局部有增长
但是
终究在吃后面的寿司的时候
是会递捡的
那例如说你可能
吃第六个寿司
然后吃第
就像你说的
这是一个
这个
寿司店的挑战赛
如果你吃下了第三十个寿司
今天就免单了
那你吃前27
哦
超级
痛苦
吃到第三十个寿司
哦
这个寿司好爽
今天免费了
那这个局部是可以有差距的
但是
终究会
那有的经济学家是说
不会
不会编辑效用地减的东西
就只有健康的寿命
但是
这个就是偏哲学的想法
就是我认为还是会编辑效用地减
就是
他的想法是说
如果你可以活两百年的话
那你再活两百年
你接下来那两百年只要是
你是健康的
那你就会一样快乐
但是
我觉得应该会越活越无聊啦
就是梅林如果活个
三千年
应该
应该是活到无聊到不行
就是
其实每一天
都
都差不多
就世界上能够发生的事
就是
几乎都被你体验完了
像我才活
三十年出头
我就觉得
我已经体验很多事情
如果活三百年
搞不好可以学习的速度又在增加
然后
可能可以体验一百倍的事情
哇
那应该真的是无聊到不行
好啦
这个
好
不然我们来一个
快要中场休息
我们来一个小互动好了
问一些不找边际的问题
就是
你觉得
这个
如果你有
无限
也不要无限
好了
持续延长的健康的寿命的话
你觉得
会边际效用递减吗
就是
我们用
三十年为一个单位好了
如果你已经
活了
一百岁
但是你还是超健康
那你觉得你
再活一百到一百三十岁
跟从一百三十岁到一百六十岁
你觉得
一百活到一百三十岁
跟一百三十岁活到一百六十岁
哪一段时间你觉得你会比较开心
你的开心会减损还是增加
还是差不多
好不好
我们问一些不找边际的问题
有没有人想回答
是不是有什么
小礼品
有小礼品
太好了
题目可以再一次吗
好
我们是说
你觉得
因为都是
应该人很难活到的
时间
你觉得
你从
一百岁活到一百三十岁
的这段时间会比较开心
还是一百三十岁活到一百六十岁的这段时光
会比较开心
然后我们先讲好
当时的科技
你都是完美的健康的寿命
就是
就像你现在一样健康好了
就是跟你现在这么年轻的时候一样健康
当时没有变得更不健康
就是没有变老了
好
有没有人要来回答一下
我觉得有可能会是
一百三十岁到一百六十岁
因为
理论上来讲
如果依照现在科技到一百岁的时候
我能体验的东西应该是差不多
但是
但时间过久的时候
科技有可能有显著的爆炸
就是你可能会体验到
目前人类还没有体验过的事情
OK
好
他提出了一个
蛮有趣的观念
他说后面的三十年
比较开心
因为
越后面的寿命
经历到的科技是越增加的
像三十年前
我们就没有现在的这些智慧型手机嘛
然后
还可以用VR看A片
就是
就是你可以体验到很多
以前体验不到的快乐
对不对
那到时候
这个VR可以拿来干嘛
可能就
更有趣一点了
对不对
对
超过目前人类的想象之类的
好好好
好
那我
好像要到中堂休息时间是吗